và giảm dẫn từng đồ và sáng xương này
là xuống cấp 147,000 mấy mấy tâm bảo cách mống cải quảng lình
khoảng 6,5 km về video.
Và giữa bảo là đến 1 giữa sáng hình này
cường đổ bảo sĩ giảm dùng cấp 147,000 mấy một
sật cấp 147 khi ở trên đến lệm vên bởi tình quảng tây Trung Quốc
và khả năng đến chia sếu mai, 257,
vùng tâm bảo sẽ đi vào cuối vực từ quảng lình, đến 2 phòng
với cường đổ khoảng cấp 147,000 mấy mấy hình chỉ điện 2,000 mấy tư dởi
là phía bác vị tuyến mấy tâm về năm lộ vì bác
phía tây kinh tuyến tư một trong mấy tâm lộ tình đồng.
Từ gần sáng mai, chỉ đến đến vên bình quảng lình đến lệm vình
có gió mạnh dân lệm cấp sau đến cấp bẩy
vùng cình tâm bảo cấp tâm đến cấp chiến sẽ cấp mấy một
Hôm vực sâu trong đất lệm phía đông bắt bộ
có gió mạnh cấp năm có nơi cấp sau sẽ cấp mạnh cấp tâm.